y nuestro cuerpo suda cuando está
caliente cuando el ambiente es caluroso
y tal vez se han dado cuenta de que suda
para poder enfriarse y que no se
sobrecaliente pero cómo funciona eso que
lo causa bueno lo que permite que ocurra
ese proceso químico o mejor dicho
proceso físico para que el cuerpo se
enfríe es el enfriamiento evaporativo
enfriamiento
evaporativo
mientras el sudor se evapora eso provoca
que el cuerpo se enfríe pero como ocurre
eso bueno visualicemos esto un poco
supongamos que este es nuestro brazo
intentaré dibujar
este es nuestro brazo y supongamos que
tiene algunas gotas de sudor porque
estamos en un lugar caluroso aquí
tenemos varias gotas de sudor pero si
hacemos un acercamiento al sudor
podremos ver qué consiste en moléculas
de agua el sudor es principalmente h2o
ahora cuando hablamos de la temperatura
de algo estamos hablando de la energía
cinética promedio cada molécula tiene
una energía cinética diferente todo se
está moviendo en diferentes direcciones
imaginemos que esta molécula tiene más
energía cinética y se mueve en esa
dirección pero a lo mejor ésta tiene una
energía cinética menor y se mueve en
esta dirección y tal vez ésta tiene una
energía cinética media y se mueve en
esta dirección pero a lo mejor esta
molécula tiene mucha energía cinética y
se mueve en esta dirección
entonces ya hemos hablado de que los
puentes
de hidrógeno que se forman en el agua
entre las terminales parciales negativas
y las terminales parciales positivas
mantienen unidas las moléculas de agua
aún cuando las moléculas se mueven son
los puentes de hidrógeno los que le dan
al agua esa cohesión pero si de repente
recuerden estábamos hablando de la
energía cinética promedio aún si nos
encontramos a temperatura ambiente y la
energía cinética promedio no es muy alta
si tenemos moléculas individuales con
una energía cinética muy alta y si son
moléculas que se encuentran cerca de la
superficie su energía cinética es
suficiente para romper los puentes de
hidrógeno que formaron con otras
moléculas de agua y superar la presión
atmosférica supongamos que estas
moléculas son moléculas gaseosas en la
atmósfera a liberarse nada de lo que
tenemos aquí forza a estas moléculas
para que regresen y formen nuevamente
puentes
de hidrógeno por ejemplo esta molécula
se puede liberar y convertirse en vapor
de agua y estará tan lejos de otras
moléculas de agua que no se podrán
formar nuevamente los puentes de
hidrógeno pero qué ocurre al vapor
izarse por medio de este proceso de
evaporación si las partículas con mayor
energía cinética o algunas de esas
partículas pueden escapar qué pasará con
la energía cinética promedio bueno como
todo lo que tiene una mayor energía
cinética podrá escapar o al menos es más
probable que escape entonces la energía
cinética promedio disminuye la energía
cinética promedio
disminuye otra forma de verlo es que la
temperatura disminuye la temperatura
disminuye porque como esas moléculas se
transforman en vapor de agua tendrán la
energía cinética más alta la energía es
transferida a ellas y entonces escaparan
así nos queda una energía cinética
promedio menor y tal vez me diga bueno y
como es que mi mano se enfría verá
nuestras manos también están hechas de
moléculas supongamos que estas son las
moléculas de la superficie de su mano
tienen una cierta energía cinética
promedio están vibrando en su lugar
sobre todo porque hablamos de algo
sólido están vibrando están unidas de
alguna forma y supongamos que tenemos
algunas moléculas de agua en la
superficie
voy a dibujar les las dibujaré de color
azul
esta es una molécula de h2o
aquí tenemos otra h2o y por acá tenemos
otra h2o y están unidas por puentes de
hidrógeno ok
como las moléculas de agua con mayor
energía cinética pueden escapar
supongamos que esta molécula escapa así
la energía cinética promedio de lo que
se queda es menor y cuando la
temperatura disminuye las moléculas de
nuestro cuerpo que estaban calientes por
lo que sea que ocurre en nuestro cuerpo
bueno ahora pueden encontrarse con esas
moléculas de agua y vibrar incrementando
su energía cinética y las moléculas que
nuevamente tengan una energía cinética
mayor podrán escapar entonces una forma
de verlo es que todo el calor se use
para permitir que esas moléculas de agua
escapen para poder vaporizarse con lo
que el calor va dejando el cuerpo y eso
permite que se enfríe así que el
enfriamiento sucede conforme el calor se
va así es como funciona el
miento evaporativo